hey guys welcome to a brand new video uh
today I'm going to be flipping from 1gp
in freeo play uh which is going to be
exceedingly challenging mainly just the
initial uh couple flips because there's
a limited amount of items in free to
play and uh a lot of people so snagging
an item for 1gp is going to be
challenging uh I may have to switch it
quite a few times uh but yeah this is
the most requested idea from my last one
and uh yeah so let's get this a try uh
so to start with I'm honestly just
looking for any item that I could
possibly buy for 1 GP I looked at bronze
items uh just some random ones you
haven't you just don't use and uh
they're being merched by somebody so
I've decided on this one random item the
white toy horsey we'll give that a shot
we'll see if we can buy it for 1 GP if
not I'll have to come back and change it
but this is definitely have to be done a
couple times this has a very low Buy
rate as so we'll leave it in
and see if it ends up
buying okay so it's been a little while
and the white to horsey has not bought
uh so I didn't really want to do this
but I think I'm going to go with the
same item that a friend used in his
video which was the Bronze
Warhammer and give that a shot I mean if
it worked for him maybe it'll work for
me uh so we'll leave this end for
another couple hours and see if it ends
up buying or maybe longer than that
maybe a day all right there it is the
bronze Warhammer came in at one g GP
apparently it's the miracle item for uh
freet toplay people who only have one GP
uh so there we go bronze war ammer is
coming through uh I'll try selling off
for 10
GP and yeah hopefully when that sells we
can go back and buy some more and then
we'll finally actually have some money
to flip some of uh some other items I am
interested in okay there we go we sold
the bronze Warhammer for 10 GP uh there
we go we can go ahead and put another
offer in for that uh cuz I spent a long
time looking for an item to put in and
uh this was the only one that ended up
working this is all from earlier so
don't worry about that um and yes so
we'll go ahead and put another offering
for bronze warhammers I'll just do 10
because I don't honestly have any idea
what else I can buy I've tried a bunch
of other things and yeah we'll see how
many we can buy and how many I end up
managing to sell all right guys we have
the bronze warhammers coming through uh
10 of them uh for 10 GP each to G give
us 100 coins which is awesome if we have
a look at the on tracker which is a
sponsor of mine I'm going to be using
them to look at a lot of the prices uh
but for the most part I'm just looking
at at the quantity per day you can see
here that uh these must be
merchesi so to start with I'm going to
go put another offering for those bronze
warhammers uh cuz they have just been so
good and uh just nice to get some
starting cash more and uh we'll do
20 of those and now we're going to have
a look for another item next up I was
having a look at the bronze plate skirt
uh an item that nobody really needs but
occasionally someone might want to buy
it uh for whatever reason or not uh so
let's go have a look in the grand
exchange here bronze plate
skirt and we got 80 GP
now I'll try buying it
for let's see can we get three of these
if we do like 26 each yeah well yeah 26
and that will use all of our money all
right so hopefully this will buy and
I'll come back with some
sales okay good news guys uh I did
manage to sell off the bronze plate
skirts for 400 GP each uh which is
awesome and the bronze warhammers didn't
another flip of those although they took
quite a bit longer to come through than
last time but anyway we got 200 GP there
and now we're up to a respectable 1400
GP now I'm going to move on to I think a
trimmed armor piece
now I've been looking through a couple
but I decided on the mythal kite Shield
t uh just kind of a random item and I'm
going to try buying them
for uh I don't know maybe we could try
to get
two like 700 each pretty well okay we'll
try buying it for $699 and then uh we
can afford two of them then and I'll be
back in a
bit okay so I ended up switching it up
to the mythal full Helm te I left the
kite shield in for a while and it didn't
end up buying it all uh so we bought the
mythal full Helms for about 500 each and
I did end up selling them for this 1100
showing on G tracker so that is going to
be uh double my initial amount uh so
we're up to
25.97 and now I think I'm just going to
go ahead and just buy uh four of these I
guess uh
well five actually uh so that will end
up with having I'll end up with about 5k
after this which should be awesome and
the items didn't come through crazy
quick but they're steady so what I'm
going to end up doing is just going
ahead and buying five more of these for
501 we just have enough for that perfect
and then do coins is not a big deal and
yeah so about 47 to 50 these are coming
through today so these flip reasonbly
quickly only took about 3 or 4 hours to
do this and yeah we'll come back
hopefully with another sale okay guys so
all five of the mythal full Helms have
come through for 1,100 each that's going
to leave us at 5,500 coins which is
really awesome now uh moving forward the
next item that I looked at that looked
actually really promising I kind of wish
I had done before is the adamant Helm H4
are more realistically any of these
Helms but we're looking at the H4 right
now hasn't sold much in the last well
this only 4 hours or so but I think I
should be able to buy it for 404 we try
buy let's just try buying them for 500
adamant helm
age4 and I'll do 501 and we'll just do
five of these guys and finally maybe one
more item to do okay next up I think I
might just do the admin Helm H1 just
another one of the heraldic Helms going
from 1,00 to 3500 is still extremely
good uh might take a while to sell again
but it should shouldn't take more than a
couple hours I wouldn't think so let's
go ahead and buy the adamant Helm 1 and
we'll put it in for 1,000 and one and do
three of them okay so we'll be back in
maybe a day or so all right guys a
couple of more successful flips uh the
admin uh H4 Helms we sold for 3,400 and
the H1s for
3700 uh netting us a really nice profit
and we're up to 28k in total uh the Adam
H4 Helms we made about 15K on in the
other Helms we made about uh seven seven
or eight uh so now I went ahead and had
a look at the G tracker highest margin
page now this is for free to play and
this is for any items under 20,000 I'm
limited it down to and looks like
there's quite a few good options here
I'm leaning towards an item like the
Easter egg or um I've never actually
heard of that item honestly or maybe the
sted a body G but first I'm going to put
an offer in for the Easter eggs because
of how good a margin is for how cheap
and it does seem to trade a fair amount
too let's go have a quick look at the
item here five and two for buying how
much daily 557 to 700 now that's a lot
uh I think it might have something to do
with the Gay Pride event maybe but uh
anyway the limit's 50 so we got a good
amount of room still so let's go ahead
and buy the Easter egg and uh we'll put
an offer in for let's do
1701 and uh actually I'm going to put
pretty much all the money in here CU
this looks pretty promising uh we'll do
16 of them and we'll come back when they
have all sold all right we got some
Easter eggs coming in really good flip
for those ones actually uh 60k and we
bought them all for 27 so we doubled our
money and this was actually a very quick
flip I did not even know about this item
ever before and I don't let's have a
look at the yeah I don't think this item
was as popular but I don't know it still
trades quite a bit and uh still looking
good I'm just going to go ahead and buy
more of these there's no reason not to
uh 1701
and let's just price check one of these
actually we got the money to and I'd
rather just know for sure uh so we'll
buy one for okay wo that was close uh
buy one for
5K oh right in the nose for that one
nice and uh going to sell it for
one and
1616 so that will help us a little bit
I'll buy them for
1620 and
uh I do 35
fiveish all right looks good we'll come
back hopefully with another 36 of these
flipped okay so 33 Easter eggs have come
through uh so we've successfully merged
off of the Gay Pride event uh woohoo
that's awesome good to hear uh so we'll
take those I well anyway I think that's
what people want these for maybe not
though either way uh so that's 122k that
is a really really good flip for the
amount of money we're at next up I'm
thinking of flipping another item from
the Gay Pride and that is
poison I don't need to go too much in
depth about this but anyway uh well
let's go ahead and uh just price check
this item uh 2K oh god well I'll try it
find it for
2K oh my God uh okay well let's let's
just we'll price check this might as
well uh
3K and 2500 oh my God and uh we'll sell
it off for well 14 is it going to sell
for much
300 okay so let's go ahead and uh well
let's go buy some of these we'll go
for 50 poisons not sure if we'll get
those all or sell them all but anyway
we'll give it a try okay next up I'm
going to try the steel kite Shield t h
now looks like a 28k margin on that uh
let's go have a look on G tracker
and okay it bugged out a little bit uh
we'll try just buying it for the price
of uh that is listed here for about 20K
roughly steel kite Shield T and well
it's 20K a little high maybe a little
bit less uh usually up to well 60 now
we're down to 20 not less do 20K uh 21k
and I will
buy um I'll go for five okay so we'll be
back in a bit this may take a while so I
may only buy half of these guys cuz
they're going to take a lengthy amount
of time to sell we'll be back in a while
okay another bunch of great flips coming
through uh the steel kite Shield by far
is the best thing we flipped so far 64k
I sold each one of those for and we only
bought them for 21k so netting us huge
profit on these mind you did have to
wait a long time for this to come
through uh poisons pretty sure I hit a
bind limit actually but either way did
manage to sell for 2500 uh netting us
about uh 30k and that really good
margins uh as you can see even in free
topl there are really good margin you
get on some items mainly uh these clue
scroll items but there are some other
random things you can take advantage of
as well uh like that like that's an
amazing flip even for pay to play uh
putting us at
328k so I hop back on G tracker now I'm
looking at uh more uh trimmed armor
pieces as well as this golden apron this
will probably come through quicker than
this but I think I'll just put an offer
in for a couple of these
and uh maybe around
30k and hopefully we can sell it for the
90k listed there uh well it was anyway
let's give it a try uh so we'll put in
for the bronze plate
legs bronze plate legs
G and uh yeah look at that it says acely
trade 150 so we'll give it a try 33k and
we'll just go for one of these and next
up is the golden apron uh which looks
like should be buying for 203k and
selling for
256 uh which is pretty nice and golden
apron put it in for
205k and that's probably all well 90k
that's a fair amount of money so let's
find one more thing and last up I'm
going to try the studed chaps G not
super excited on this item but H well
couldn't find anything better at the
time stud the chaps G
and we'll toss them in there
[Music]
for uh 59k all right so we got uh just
three singular items let's see how they
do and I'll be back in a while okay so I
have the flips coming back in and I was
going to buy the golden apron but didn't
end up working out uh so I did double
down on the bronze plate legs which
worked out quite nicely and uh sold them
all for 64k each as well as a 10K margin
on the studded chaps bringing our cash
ATT up to 431 which is not bad
and yeah so on each um bronze plate legs
I made about 30k and on the St of chap I
only made 10K so not anything too crazy
now one other trimmed piece of armor I
want to try now is the iron set and I
was looking at the iron kite Shield uh
the iron kite Shield G so let's have a
look on G tracker quickly so I'm going
to be honest here I was actually on my
main and I ended up buying this item uh
so I actually know what the margin is
now tracker isn't showing a huge margin
here but um I still think I'm going to
buy it because I kind of cheated
hopefully he can forgive me here but
anyway I'm going to try buying it for
126k and
um selling it for
164 uh now is that much higher than
normally would be at 126 uh no that
seems pretty good actually so we'll go
ahead and buy three of these and and I
think that's it and I'll come back
hopefully when these have sold all right
guys so that's it the iron kite Shield
is through and uh I'm actually going to
be stopping the episode here now I
thought 500 mil or 500k would be more
appropriate for free to play because the
amount of time it takes to actually do
these flips can be a little bit daunting
and uh free to play Just inherently
takes longer so hopefully you get the
idea by now I'm just flipping low volume
rare items that are available in free
play and just getting really good
margins uh because when you have a free
toplay account laying around it's
totally fine to just let offers come
through solely it's not like you're
wasting membership you don't have to
worry about anything like that uh so
having these slow offers can be super
beneficial uh so you can see this the
very last one here I sold all of them
for 49k we bought them for 378 it took a
while but it it paid off I at 5 142k all
from flipping just from a one GP start
uh so yeah for that reason I'm going to
end it now I don't really see the point
of continuing on past this point
especially since there isn't a huge
diverse amount of items that even be
flipping past this it's mostly just
trimmed armor maybe I could do some
gilded but that's long past a mill
anyway and that's going to take just way
too long all right guys so hope you guys
enjoyed the video uh if you did uh I
appreciate if you let uh me know if
there's any other ideas that are kind of
related to this you'd like to see I know
this is a freet to-play one was the most
popular one but maybe a challenge
another restriction to it somehow I
don't know I haven't really saw about
too much but you guys seem to have some
good ideas usually and yeah thanks for
watching guys and I'll see you guys in
the next video
[Music]